moscou fou défend sa décision d'expulser
des diplomates européens tout en
assurant vouloir développer ses
relations avec l'union européenne
réactions après la déclaration hier de
josep borrell de retour de sa visite en
russie le chef de la diplomatie
européenne s'est dit inquiet du refus
des autorités russes d'engager un
dialogue plus constructif avec le e en
filigrane l'expulsion de trois
diplomates accusée d'avoir participé à
des manifestations non autorisées en
soutien à l'opposant l'excès navalni la
correspondance un discours d'antoine
claireaux trois jours après l'entretien
de josep borrell avec sergey lavrov la
russie s'étonne du changement de ton
entre le moment où le chef de la
diplomatie européenne se trouvait encore
à moscou et les déclarations faites
depuis son retour à bruxelles
en effet dans un twitt diffusé dimanche
josette borel reproche par exemple à la
russie de ne pas saisir l'opportunité de
créer un dialogue plus constructif avec
l'union européenne
alors qu'il avait évoqué je cite un
dialogue ouvert et franc en conférence
de presse
deux jours plus tôt nous avons été
surpris de prendre connaissance des
évaluations des résultats de sa visite
par josep borrell qui contraste
nettement avec ses déclarations faites
lors de la conférence de presse à moscou
moscow regrette donc il n'est pas
présenté le fond de sa pensée au moment
de la conférence de presse alors qu'il
en avait l'occasion
ce qui fait dire au ministère russe des
affaires étrangères que josep borrell
aurait été recadré à son retour à
bruxelles
personne ne l'a limité ni dans le temps
ni en termes de format peut être après
être revenu à bruxelles le chef de la
diplomatie européenne at il reçu des
éclaircissements concernant ce sur quoi
ils auraient dû mettre l'accent mais
dans ce cas là cela ne fait que
confirmer par qui et comment est élaboré
dans les faits la politique européenne
sauf qu'entre temps trois diplomates
européens un allemand un polonais et un
suédois avait été renvoyé de russie
accusée d'avoir participé à des
rassemblements non autorisés en soutien
alexeï navalni le 23 janvier dernier
et ce alors que josep borrell étaient
toujours sur place ce qui a été vécu à
bruxelles comme une humiliation
suffisamment pour qu'une pétition soit
lancée à l'initiative des pays baltes
pour demander le remplacement du haut
représentant de l'union européenne pour
les affaires étrangères